Thank you for having me and thank you so much for everyone for making the time
both in the room and on the live stream.
So as Rachel said,
this is my book I wrote.
It came out actually the same day as Rachel's Book.
Our books are twins.
Um,
I like to think of them.
and I'm going to tell you about the book,
the main concepts in the book.
But before I do that,
I want you all to do something.
I want you all to think,
think about a time that you had a conflict with someone.
Maybe it was at work,
maybe it was your boss,
maybe it wasn't your parent or your spouse or your teenage kid.
And maybe it was this morning,
or maybe it was last week or maybe last month.
Now I want you to think about how that conflict made you feel.
And I want people to shout out just the one word.
What's the one word that describes how you felt?
Stressed.
Frustrated.
Unheard.
Irate.
If I hear that right.
Angry.
Okay.
I tried to,
to p beautify it up a little bit.
Irate.
Yeah.
Anything else dismissed?
Sad,
I did this talk once and someone said strangled.
And I was really concerned about how they handled conflict that their
organization,
what I've never heard when I've asked people do this is energized,
excited,
invigorated,
respected.
Um,
and that's because this is the natural human response when we get into a
conflict.
Conflict is when we feel threatened,
our identity,
our resources,
our needs we're having needs and wants that aren't being met and we have a
natural struck stress response,
right?
So we ended up having our heart rate go up.
We have higher levels of stress.
Um,
we lose access to the prefrontal cortex.
We go into what Dan Goldman calls a Mig hijack and we're just not making good
rational decisions.
Now I believe that it doesn't have to be that way.
I believe that organizations should in need to have disagreements and conflicts,
but most often they're handling in ways that are unprofessional and
unproductive.
And that's because we don't have the skills to have productive disagreements.
And more importantly,
we've gotten to this place,
both in our organizations but in our country,
certainly at large,
that disagreement actually equals unkindness.
And this is something that's really detrimental to human interaction.
So I'm on a personal mission.
Why I wrote this book is that I want people to think of conflict and
disagreement as a normal,
healthy,
productive part of interacting with other human beings.
And when we disagree with compassion,
empathy and kindness,
it has lots of positive benefits.
What?
But unfortunately what's happening is,
um,
the exact opposite.
People are becoming meaner to each other.
This is a chart,
um,
that comes from Chris Porath.
She wrote a book called mastering civility.
I highly recommend it.
She studies uncivil behavior at work.
What she's seen is that over the last 20 so or so years,
we've people are reporting more and more rudeness at work.
So this is a number of people who really support someone being rude to them at
work in the last,
at least once in the last month,
right?
So we're getting meaner to each other and this Tate has its costs.
So a night to 2008 study done by CPP,
which is the people who create the Myers Briggs test have a study that showed
that on average are spending 2.8 hours a week dealing with conflict at work.
Now that's a lot of time and I imagined since the study was done about 10 years
ago that it's actually gotten worse.
And that same study equated this with $359 billion and paid hours.
It's even worse if you're a manager.
A study by the American Management Association,
um,
showed that the average manager is spending 18 to 26% of their time.
Now,
full disclosure,
this was a study done in 1976.
Um,
this is the study that's most cited around how much managerial time I would
pause it and that we actually spend even more.
And I've seen more recent surveys that show some managers report spending up to
40% of their time dealing with complex.
This also leads to performance issues.
So 65%.
A study by the bent pen behavioral corporation found that 65% of problems,
performance problems are linked to strained relationships.
So it's most often what's happening in between people that's causing these
problems.
So we're being mean to each other.
It's costs taking up our time,
it's costing US money,
it's leading to performance problems.
What are we to do now?
First and foremost,
we have to embrace conflict as not a negative.
If you said to me,
I work in a conflict free office,
I would say that sounds pleasant but probably not very productive,
right?
So we have to embrace conflict as a normal,
healthy part of organizations.
Now,
all of this,
um,
these stats that are just reported,
show that what have led to what Bill Fisher and William Ury who wrote getting
to,
yes,
they're the Harvard negotiation project said conflict as a growth industry.
This is a quote from their book.
Now this is great news for me as a conflict expert.
This is bad news for the rest of the world,
right?
So what we need to think about is first,
like I said,
embrace conflict as a normal,
healthy part of interacting with people and think about the positive outcomes
that come from complex first and foremost.
More successful work outcomes.
If I see a project one way and you see it another and we have to discuss that
you know our different opinions to come to a solution it the chances are the
worst outcome is going to be better,
right?
If marketing is pushing for one thing and sales is for another,
that natural tension organizations is going to make the end product better even
if it's slightly uncomfortable or very uncomfortable for the people in the
process.
Second of all,
you have the opportunities to learn and grow.
The more that you are forced to think about your position to articulate why you
disagree,
what your points are,
the more you're going to learn about what's important to you,
the more you are going to expand as a person.
Third,
you're going to have improved relationships.
Now I have a 10 year old daughter.
She understands this intuitively.
She came back from a sleepover a few weekends ago and told me,
uh,
she had the best time and I said,
great,
why did you have the best time?
And she said,
Sophie and I fought the entire night.
We fought about what movie we're gonna Watch.
We thought about what time we should go to bed,
where we're going to sleep.
I said,
that doesn't actually sound that fun.
She said,
no,
but now we're BFFs.
Right?
So she understood.
When you go through a tough situation with someone where you have to do all that
negotiation,
you end up having a stronger bond.
And this,
and the research shows this is true at work as well.
And lastly,
that leads to the last positive outcome that I'm going to talk about,
which is job satisfaction.
So if you feel like you can disagree with your colleagues,
if you're not walking on egg shows,
worried that a disagreement is gun going to come up,
you're much more satisfied at work.
Now how do we get these positive outcomes?
That's what my book does.
It takes research from neuroscience,
emotional intelligence,
experts,
management,
science,
and makes it sort of boils it down to an a very practical,
straightforward approach and to how to candle conflict.
So what I want to share with you today from the book or some tools and concepts
that will hopefully make conflict less stressful for you and help you reap these
positive outcomes that I just talked about.
And that's because dealing with conflict is an essential skill in today's
organizations.
Just chatting with a few view at the beginning here before we got started,
it's clear,
you all know that there are conflicts on the horizon or that you're experiencing
complex in order to function in today's organizations,
you must have these skills.
So the first concept I want to talk to you about is that most of us self select
into one of two categories.
We either tend to avoid conflict or we tend to seek it.
So avoiders and it's exactly how it sounds,
right?
Avoiders are people who probably want to hide under the desk when the
disagreement comes up that they really value harmony,
they value relationships.
Anytime things get tense,
they want to back away or placate,
they want things to go smoothly.
Seekers on the other hand are people who really lean into conflict when it comes
up.
They're the ones whose body language is perhaps a little more aggressive when,
when things happen,
um,
in a meeting or um,
you know,
in the hallway with,
with someone and oftentimes they care most about directness and honesty.
Now I self select as a seeker.
I was the kid on the playground that when a fight erupted,
I would scream,
fight and try to get as many people to come observe what was happening,
partly because I knew that I could then broker,
um,
you know,
the disagreement and see,
see if we could get to a solution.
But also because I find uncomfortable situations and fights.
Really interesting.
I have,
I don't know if anyone's been listening to the new Esther Perel podcast.
She's a couple's therapist.
Yeah.
So she's doing,
she's somehow got couples to do live or recorded therapy sessions with her.
Um,
my husband and I tried to listen to this together and my husband who is an
avoider at his core was so uncomfortable.
It was like,
how can you listen to this?
I was like,
this is fascinating.
I couldn't,
couldn't get enough of it.
I highly,
highly recommend it.
Even if you're an avoider would help you maybe do a little bit of aversion
therapy there.
So,
quick question.
Yeah.
It's called,
um,
where should we begin?
And it's actually,
I think it's just on audible now.
It should be on iTunes,
but,
um,
so I just want to get a quick survey in the room,
of how many avoiders and secrets,
how many people think they're avoiders.
Okay.
I would say about half the room.
And how many people think they're seekers?
Yeah.
About half.
And how many think they're both?
Yeah,
right or neither.
Yeah.
So that it's of course normal that we would sometimes seek and sometimes avoid.
Right?
You might be an avoider with your boss and a secret with your mother,
right?
You might be an avoider with your friends,
but a seeker at work and that's what you want to,
um,
that's what you want to do is be able to figure out when,
which style is going to work for you and understand your default style.
So if you have a style that you tend to avoid and every time a conflict comes
up,
you're hiding under the table,
you have to think about how can I compensate for that?
How can I make this a little bit more palatable to me?
Or if you tend to seek and you notice that people around you are leaving the
room or scared to interact with you,
right,
then you need to figure out how do I compensate for that?
Now in order to,
um,
have a rational approach to conflict,
right?
To make those good choices,
to know what your style is and to compensate it,
it really helps to put a little bit of distance between you in the situation and
to get out of what I was describing before as a mcdilla hijack where you don't
have access to your prefrontal cortex in order to do that.
What I recommend and what a lot of the book is about is how to analyze each
conflict that you're in,
right?
So you want to take each,
there's four steps that I described in the book.
Number one,
you want to understand your counterpart.
Now we are naturally narcissistic and when we feel threatened,
we think about how we are suffering.
We think about what,
what's happening to us,
what's our perspective on the situation.
It is incredibly helpful to think about the other person.
What is it that they're going through?
Are they a seeker avoider?
What could be causing this behavior?
Right?
Second,
you want to identify the type of conflict.
I talk to people about conflict all the time.
When people find out,
I write this book,
they want it by wrote this book.
They want to tell me about every fight they've had at work in the last week.
Most people assume that the conflict there in is a relationship conflict,
meaning that it's sort of personal issue between two people.
They feel disrespected or someone has said something snarky.
But most conflicts at work actually start as one of three.
Um,
other types,
and I'll go over these.
Like I said,
most of us assume that there's a relationship conflict going on,
but more often than not,
it's actually starts as a task conflict.
So this is a disagreement over the goal of a project or the objective,
what you're trying to achieve.
So I think the goal of a project is to increase revenue.
You think it is to improve customer satisfaction,
right?
The second is process.
So you,
we may agree that the goal is to increase revenue,
but I think we should do that by rolling out to our entire,
you know,
group of markets at one time.
You think we should do pilot it first?
So it's a disagreement over the how we're actually going to get there.
And then last,
there's complex over status or power who gets to make the call.
And this is extremely common in,
in flat organizations where there's con teams that are shaping and reshaping all
the time.
Right now,
of course,
conflicts rarely fall into one discrete category.
More often than not,
they're actually a combination of these things.
And what I see most often is something that starts as task or process quickly
devolves into a personal conflict.
So you and I are disagreeing over what the goal of the project is.
I start sending you late nights,
snarky emails and it quickly becomes a personal issue.
Now,
the third step,
so,
so before when you enter a conflict,
you want to ask yourself what type of conflict are you having?
Right?
That is an important step because once you know that,
you can begin to dig into how to actually solve it.
Because if you assume it's a personal conflict,
those are the hardest conflicts to actually resolve.
But if you can actually solve the task or the process conflict,
the personal stuff is going to be much more easy to resolve.
So now the third step is to determine your goal.
And I like to say if your goal in the situation is to prove that your
counterpart wrong,
find another goal.
Now that might feel good in the near term,
right?
It might feel good to say I was right in this situation or you were wrong.
Or what I hear most often these days is his behavior was unacceptable and until
he accepts his behavior is unacceptable.
We can't move on,
right.
If that,
if your goal is just to prove someone's behavior is unacceptable,
you are not going to solve that conflict cause no one wants to admit that their
behavior was unacceptable.
If you can actually decide,
okay,
my goal here is to save this relationship or my goal is to get this project
quickly as done as quickly as possible so I never have to work with this person
again.
That's a goal that's going to help serve you much better.
Right?
And that's a goal you're going to be able to achieve and that will lead to the
fourth step,
which is to pick your option.
Now in most US companies that I talk to,
they think of having a discussion about conflict as sitting down and hashing
things out and that's the direct approach.
But you actually have several other options for handling a conflict and you use
them all the time and may not even know.
So number one,
you can do nothing.
We do this all the time.
Jeanne Brett,
who runs the dispute resolution center at Northwestern University calls this
lumping it and we do this.
You get this snarky email or someone raises their voice in a meeting or someone
says something that's completely off base and undermines your authority and you
just sort of ignore it and move on and it's a great option.
It's a great option is particularly if you don't have much power in this
situation,
if you're dealing with someone who is unreasonable or if you realize making a
big deal of it is going to make things worse rather than just move on.
Now there's a caveat about the do nothing option.
If you are an avoider and you're like,
oh,
I love the do nothing option,
I love,
I do that all the time.
You need to check yourself because you're likely doing it because you're afraid
to have some conversations,
some difficult conversations.
The other caveat is doing nothing that going back to your desk and stewing and
not getting your work done and gossiping with another friend about how awful
that person is,
is not doing nothing that's actually doing something.
So in order to exercise this option,
you really have to be willing to let it go and truly let it go.
Now,
of course you might try to do nothing and realize it's not working.
You're losing sleep,
you're having the conversation in your head on the car ride home,
right?
But if if you're,
that's okay,
you can then move to one of the other options.
There's no harm in that.
Another option is to address it indirectly.
I often talk to organizations,
particularly I noticed in financial service organizations,
I bring this up and they're like,
oh yeah,
that's the passive aggressive option,
right?
That's where you would try to get your needs met without actually having to talk
about it.
But this is a perfectly good option in situations where addressing it directly,
again,
maybe you're dealing with it someone who's unreasonable or with an extreme
conflict avoider.
So talking to a third party who can maybe intervene on your behalf is completely
appropriate.
This is also an appropriate option and in cultures where saving face is really
important.
As a,
in a previous career as a management consultant and I was staffed on a project
in Korea for four months and it was a,
with this Korean conglomerate,
we had three different work streams for the project and at one point we came to
an impasse with our Korean counterparts where they said,
okay,
we really need to figure out which of these three workstreams we're going to
prioritize it.
Things got really heated,
really tense and finally we,
they said we're going to meet with the CEO and the COO is going to help us
decide which of these we should prioritize.
Me and my American counterparts are like,
great,
let's get in the room,
let's hash it out.
We have,
we know what we think should happen.
They know what they think should happen.
We're going to be able to sort this all out together and we get in the room and
the CEO starts telling this long story about the founding of the company and um,
you know why it was all about the people in his family and providing for the
people who worked there.
And after about 20 minutes of course we're listening to all this through an
interpreter and looking at the interpreter sort of confused like this is really
what he's saying.
Weren't we going to decide which work stream we're going to focus on?
After about 20 minutes he ends the story and everyone gets up in the meeting,
seems to be over and we walk out and my American counterparts in our standing
and sitting room like what just happened?
Like boy and our Korean or like did you not hear?
He told us were prior to prioritizing the HR work stream because it was all
about people and he had used the metaphor and the story of the founding of the
company to put us in direction without ever having to discuss the conflict we
are having.
And that was a very appropriate way to solve the conflict in that organization.
And it worked because we had the direction we needed and we were able to,
to move forward.
And that's again,
you,
I've seen people do this very skillfully where they will tell,
have a conflict with summer and rather say we're having a conflict,
let's discuss what's going on.
They'll say,
you know,
I once had a previous job with someone where we weren't getting along and I did
this and he did this and it,
and it's sort of just dropping hints of this may be a way we can move forward
without directly addressing what's happening.
Third is addressed directly.
We'll talk a lot about that and the rest of the,
the talk about how to actually prepare for those difficult conversations and how
to have them.
Um,
and the fourth option is to exit the relationship.
Now this is what I call the last resort option.
Um,
very difficult to do in most organizations,
often hard to get a new boss,
often hard to get a new teammate.
Um,
so really this is a last resort.
If you've tried the other three options and it's not working,
you may need to find,
um,
you know,
a way to stop interacting with this person.
I talked to someone whose story is featured in the book who eventually went
after really difficult situation with her boss,
eventually went to HR and was able to sell HR on getting her to report to
someone else,
um,
without actually having to lay out everything that was going on.
So it takes a lot of skill in most organizations to make this happen,
but I like to lay it out as an option.
So those are the four steps that to analyze a complex.
And this again,
the point is to help you put distance between your reaction to the situation,
which is likely going to be narcissistic and emotional,
right?
And your reaction and your action.
So the idea is to give yourself some space before you decide exactly what to do.
Now I'm talking about this as if you have all the time in the world,
right?
As if you can say,
oh,
you know,
you just sent me an email,
I'm going to take a half an hour to go through these four steps.
More likely you'll need to buy yourself some time and in time pressured fast
moving organizations.
This can be difficult and I acknowledge that,
but there are ways that you can give yourself a little bit of space to do this
work.
Eventually you'll be able to do those four steps really quickly in your brain.
It won't take a half an hour sitting down,
opening my book,
right?
And looking through each step.
Um,
but in the moment in,
when you're first getting used to this,
you really want to take the time,
um,
you need.
So first if someone is yelling,
if things are really heated,
it is okay to walk away,
right?
What you need to do is actually own the,
the need to do that.
So you never want to say you're being unreasonable or you're screaming,
I'm going to take some five minutes.
People do not like to be assigned emotions or reactions instead of own it.
I need a few minutes to think this through or I really need to calm down.
Can I come back to you tomorrow or can I send you an email later?
Right?
You can ask for a break.
So even if you've started the discussion and then you realize I'm not being
rational here,
or he's not being rational here,
you can say,
you know what,
again,
can I take five minutes and come back to you?
Or can we take a walk around the building and talk about this later and find,
find a way to give yourself the space you need.
And then lastly,
don't hit send.
I cannot tell you how many times an email completely implodes a conflict
situation.
We cannot read tone on email.
There's amazing studies about this,
right?
We can not read tone.
We assume the worst intention when we get,
when we send an email,
we assume we're being completely clear,
transparent,
and benevolent.
When we receive an email,
we assume people are being completely unclear and route,
right?
So Co emails,
a horrible place to have it.
Have a discussion or a tense conversation.
So,
especially if you've written a really long email in response to someone who has
sent you something that you are not happy about,
don't hit send or delete the draft,
put it into a document,
save it for later.
You know,
allow yourself to vent.
But really make sure that you're not engaging over email.
Now how to prepare for the conversation.
So once you've decided,
okay,
we are going to sit down,
I need to talk to this person,
I need to stop by their desk.
How do you actually get ready?
I talk about three different types of preparation,
mental,
strategic and logistic.
So first,
mentally,
if you are going into a conversation that you think is going to be difficult and
uncomfortable,
guess what?
It is going to be difficult and uncomfortable.
So you have to change your mindset.
Think about if I went into this conversation with a positive attitude with
thinking about something I could learn,
what am I actually curious about?
Right?
What don't I know about my counterpart's perspective or the assumptions that
she's made that I can learn in this conversation,
right?
Instead of thinking about I have,
oh,
I have to give this teammate of mine this really negative feedback.
Think about I'm really doing tough work to help my teammate grow,
right?
Really put a positive frame.
And this is not sugarcoating,
right?
This is not,
you should,
it should be a genuinely positive,
um,
you know,
take on the situation.
But it,
it,
it helps so much to go into a conversation with a much more curious,
open attitude because you're going to project that to the other person.
And so much about resolving conflict is about the energy you both bring to the
conversation.
If you come in slump shoulders,
really nervous about what's happening,
fidgeting,
that's going to queue the person because of our natural instinct to mirror
another person's behavior,
that's going to cause them to do the same.
Second,
you want to take your counterpart's perspective.
So hopefully you've done this when you analyze the conflict,
but also think more deeply,
what is it,
this person that is motivating this person?
What could explain the way that they've reacted so far?
And granted,
sometimes you might want to be,
well,
he's just a passive aggressive jerk,
right?
If you come up with that explanation,
tried to come up with three more,
could it be that he's under extreme pressure?
Is he she afraid of losing her job?
Is there something going on in this person's personal life that would better
explain what's happening?
Lastly,
you want to vent,
so find your most trusted colleague,
some a friend outside the organization and just get it all out.
Because if you have all of those negative thoughts and feelings about this
person,
about the situation,
and you bring them into the conversation,
again,
you're going to really make things uncomfortable and you're going to set
yourself up for failure.
So instead,
if you can get that all out,
say it to the person,
to this trusted person,
then you'll be much more calm and collected when you go into the,
um,
into the discussion.
Now strategically,
how do you get ready?
One,
you want to plan your,
so think about what you'll say and what you won't say.
What will be helpful to the conversation and what would be likely to take the
person off.
You don't have to write it out.
You don't have to know exactly everything you're going to say because remember
you're in conversation with another person.
You cannot predict how they'll react,
but have a good sense of what it main points you want to make and jot those
down.
Have them ready,
mate.
Trust me.
If someone comes into a tense conversation looking prepared,
I am nothing but grateful,
right?
No one's going to say like you wrote your main points down.
It's incredibly helpful to have those at your ready,
especially if things start to get emotional.
You also want to prepare for multiple scenarios,
so think about what happens if I start to cry.
What happens if he gets up and walks out of the room?
What happens if we get interrupted and we only have 10 minutes,
right?
To have this conversation,
how will I react?
And the goal again,
is not to PR to map out everything you'll say and do in those situations,
but it's to make sure that you feel prepared and that you don't get blindsided.
So when something happens,
you think,
okay,
I thought something similar like this through and I'm ready.
I'm ready for this,
this unforeseen situation.
Now,
logistically,
where and when you have this conversation really matters and people often ask me
how soon after an incident do I want to have the conversation?
And what I always say is as soon as possible,
but when you're both ready to have it,
right?
So you don't want to push forward a conversation if you're not feeling like
you've done the right work,
that you're not in a good frame of mind.
If you go into the conversation feeling hyped up uncomfortable again,
it's going out.
Going to set the right tone.
So choose a time after you've had time to calm down.
Make sure you have more than enough time to have the discussion and then also
choose a good place to have it.
I often say,
especially if there's a status conflict going on that you want to,
um,
you know,
not be on anyone's territory,
go outside,
take a walk.
Um,
especially if you're dealing with a seeker,
half the conversation in a public place where they'll be on their best behavior,
less likely to yell,
right?
If you know you're a seeker and you think that the comfort of conference room is
going to make you misbehave,
take yourself outside,
ask the person to meet you in an in a neutral spot,
right?
So once you've gotten ready,
let's talk about how you actually have a productive conversation.
Once you're in the room or on the phone or however you're having this
conversation.
First you want to frame your message.
So there's three things you do to frame your message.
One,
you talk about a shared goal that you both have something that you have in
common.
So you might say,
you know,
we both really care about getting this project on time,
or we both really care that this project comes under budget.
Whatever you shared goal you have,
or we really care about what's best for the team.
Second,
you want to identify the type of conflict so you don't have to use the words
task,
process status,
but make sure it's clear that this is not about personal issues.
Talk about what's the underlying business cause or business issue that's
happening there.
And that will help depersonalize the discussion.
And then third,
you want to ask that person.
Well you want to set a collaborative intent.
You want to make sure the person knows that you're there,
not to prove your point,
not to prove them wrong,
but to actually work it out together.
So you might say,
I'm really excited we're having this conversation because I had success in this
situation.
It's gonna depend on us working together.
Or you might do what Adam Galinsky at Columbia University has found really works
and a lot of these situations,
which is to ask for advice that will show that you're being collaborative.
So it sounds a little bit like this.
You might say,
you know,
I'm,
we both really care about getting this project done on time.
I think what's really at is at issue is,
is a process conflict about how we actually solve it.
I'd love to get your advice on how we can work this through together and that
really enlist the other person that shows them.
I'm not here to just prove my point,
but I'm here to work collaboratively with you.
Second,
you want to manage your emotions.
As I mentioned,
we have a natural human instinct to want to mere another's person's behavior.
So if you're getting red in the face,
if your heart rate is rising,
your breathing is getting faster,
the other person is going to likely react in the same way.
So what you want to do is use a lot of mindfulness techniques,
right?
Focus on your breathing.
Try to imagine that you're a fly on the wall and you're just observing the
conversation and what's happening or you know,
really narrate to yourself in your head.
Give,
try to give yourself some distance from those emotions and narrate in your head
what's happening that it's,
that'll take you out of your body reaction and the stress response and really
ground you,
um,
in being there and being present.
You can also use what a lot of mindfulness experts,
there's Leah Weiss at Stanford has done a lot of interesting research about
this,
which is called anchoring.
And it's trying to sort of ground yourself in your body.
So you're either putting your,
focusing on your feet,
touching the ground,
your hand on the table,
anything again to get you,
get yourself present in your body and out of those sort of rumination,
um,
going on in your brain.
Now your main job in any difficult conversation is to listen.
And this is not because you're being altruistic or genuine,
genuine,
generous to your counterpart.
This is because it is strategic.
The more information you have about what the person's interests are and what
they want out of the situation,
the more likely are going to be able to propose a solution that meets both your
needs and their needs.
So you want to ask a lot of questions,
ask what made you think that?
What are the assumptions going into that?
Um,
you know,
tell me more.
Tell me more.
As a fantastic phrase,
especially when someone says something that you immediately want to react to
negatively and say,
that's not true.
That's inappropriate.
Try saying,
tell me more instead,
because you're going to find out a lot more information rather than shutting the
conversation down.
And lastly,
you also want to make your viewpoint heard the avoiders of the world.
We'll spend a lot of time listening if they've even managed to stay in the room,
right?
But you also want to make sure that you get your viewpoint heard.
And you might say to someone,
I really hear your perspective.
Repeat back what they hear,
but then say,
I would like to tell you my take on this situation,
help transition there that you've gone from listening mode to talking mode.
Help them understand you're about to make your point and it's important that you
have.
Sometimes we assume people understand what our interests or needs are in a
situation and very often they don't.
So making your viewpoint heard,
make sure that your interests are on the table.
Now in the process of doing all this,
sometimes even actually in the process of analyzing the complex,
sometimes a natural resolution,
um,
it just sort of evolves in the conversation.
And you'll notice a resolution because it has three hallmarks.
Number one,
it satisfies interests.
So it satisfies as many interests as possible.
It has to meet some of yours and some of your counterparts.
It doesn't have to meet all of them,
but for it to be a resolution that's going to stick,
that's going to keep the relationship intact.
It has to meet at least some of each of yours.
Second,
it has to be fair and reasonable.
Now,
what's fair to one person and reasonable to another is very different,
right?
Those are very subjective terms.
So you might think about how would this be,
um,
observed or how would this be interpreted by other people?
So if we had to write this agreement,
the disagreement that happened,
the resolution we came to and we had,
does,
you know,
distributed to everyone on our team or organization,
what everyone look at them and say,
wow,
we really got the deal in that situation.
Or would they think,
oh,
that's fair and reasonable.
Right?
And you might even evoke those words in your discussion of a resolution.
You might say,
I understand why you're proposing that,
but I can't imagine having to pitch that to my boss.
I think my boss would not think that's reasonable.
Right?
So bring in sort of third party perspectives to establish what,
what's fair and reasonable.
And lastly,
it has to leave the relationship intact.
So if you have gone through all of this and you come to a resolution but you
hate each other's guts,
that's not going to give you all those positive benefits that I talked about at
the beginning.
You're not going to have a stronger relationship,
you're not going to be happy to come to work,
right?
So it has to make sure that the relationship stays intact.
And there's a whole chapter in the book about how to repair the relationship
after a conflict.
So you might want to check that out as well.
So how do you get to that resolution when you're having the conversation?
A couple things.
One,
be creative.
So rather than saying,
I believe we should do this,
and your your counterpart come and sit back and say,
no,
I think we should do this.
Try to build on each other's ideas.
So if your counterpart throws out a potential resolution,
say yes and I think we could also do this.
Build on it.
Try to create more options,
even throwing out options that you don't think we'll really work,
because that's going to give you more interest in information about their
interest.
Because if you throw out something that's completely wackadoodle right,
they're going to say,
that would never work because of this and this and this.
And then you get more information about what matters to them and what they care
about.
You also want to collaborate this.
You cannot just criticize each other's ideas.
Think about what can we propose together?
What information,
additional information do we need?
What other stakeholders do we need to get interest from?
Right?
Work on it together.
You want to make sure that it feels like you're on the right side of the table
together,
not on opposite opposite sides.
And then lastly,
consider what you have to offer.
So oftentimes in in a difficult conversation,
we are trying to sort out what each person can give.
If you're asking your counterpart to give up something really important,
some interest that's really,
that really matters to them.
Consider what you have to offer in return.
Maybe it's on,
it's something you can help out on another project at another time.
You know,
maybe,
um,
you know,
you can do them a favor down the road,
whatever it is that's going to in Volk,
that's sort of natural law of reciprocity.
They're going to be more likely to be willing to give if you've offered
something up.
So of course I'm talking about this again as if you have all the time in the
world,
but most of us in time pressured organizations are dealing with conflicts.
That happened very quickly.
Something comes up in a meeting,
something needs to be decided today,
right?
We need to tell our bosses how this is going to be resolved.
So I just want to give you a few points of what you can do on the fly and then
I'll,
I'll take you some of your questions.
So first know your type.
No.
Whether you tend to seek or whether you avoid,
that's going to give you really important information when you start to react to
conflicts that come up.
So if you tend to be an avoider and something happens in a meeting,
you'll recognize,
okay,
this is how I always react in these situations.
I need to watch myself.
No.
What types?
The four types of conflict and name them.
Again,
you don't have to use the terms task,
process status,
but really try to depersonalize what's happening because when someone disagrees
with you,
as I've mentioned,
we start to think of that.
It's an unkind,
that person doesn't respect me.
They don't think I'm qualified to be here,
they don't think I'm good at my job.
Right?
And if you can really focus on,
actually we're disagreeing over how to get this project done,
it's going to help take some of that emotion in the,
in the personality,
out of the situation.
Make smart choices about your option.
Don't just default to hashing it out or doing nothing.
Really think through,
okay of these four options,
which is the best here,
and be ready to pivot if it doesn't,
if one option is not working,
be willing to move,
move to another and of course control your emotions.
You want to make sure,
I cannot tell you how many conversations I've seen completely go off the rails
because someone starts to raise their voice or it gets red in the face and it
just causes so much tension and discomfort.
The more you can be calm,
cool and collected,
even if the other person isn't the much more,
you're going to set that conversation on a path to success and you also,
it does not matter the content of the conversation.
The person who feels in control of their emotions is most likely the person
who's going to get what they want out of the situation.
It's what I observe all of the time when I'm doing coaching or consulting,
the people who feel in control and feel like they're making rational decisions
always have the upper hand.
So I'm going to take some questions.
If I leave you with one thing today,
I really want you to remember this,
which is that it is it,
it is your job to disagree with people.
It is your job to have opinions that differ from people.
It is what makes work good and what makes it sort of fun to be at.
So do not think of disagreement as unkindness is actually a kind thing to do if
you do it the right way.
So thank you all so much for having me.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was really good.
Thank you.
And we'll take questions.
So who has a question?
I'm going to go over here and
thank you.
Those kinds of frameworks are really helpful to me,
so I appreciate that.
Sure.
Um,
sometimes conflict arises because of the processes in a large org and a portion
of that org feels dismissed or diminished because of it in those complex happen
over time.
I'm curious about how we translate these kinds of one on one experiences to
those larger kind of conversations?
Yeah,
so a couple things.
One of which is we all work in organizations where we don't have a ton of
control over things happen,
how things happen.
So what I tell people is focus on what you can control.
It can be really easy to think about the larger cultural issues or the larger
process issues and really focus on those.
But if you are powerless to change those,
you're going to feel nothing but you know,
sort of depressed and,
and you know,
have sort of a lack of agency.
So really focus on the interactions and the human to human.
I think these frameworks definitely apply at a larger level though.
So let's say your department is,
you know,
interacting with another department that tends to feel dismissed.
You can really think about how,
you know,
can we really focus on what the actual conflict is if they come in with a sort
of a man down kind of an attitude,
how do we really focus on what we're trying to achieve?
Not that interpersonal issue.
Ultimately at the end of the day,
all of this gets played out in a one to one
or one to many,
um,
interaction.
So really focus on how you can sort of compensate or undo some of those myths
are some of those,
um,
you know,
predispositions in the interaction and oftentimes that can sort of set,
there's a Annie Mckee who wrote a great book,
you guys should have her actually called,
how to be happy at work and she talks about microcode cultures.
So we're all subject to the larger culture of our organization or our department
or our team.
But what she's observed is that people create microcultures and might just start
with two people or might start with a segment of a team where you start
interacting the way you wish people around you are in interacting.
And it starts to set the behavior,
not necessarily sometimes it,
it will impact the broader organization,
but more importantly,
it just protects you in that moment of I have this safety of this micro culture
in which I know I can behave and live my values and be happy at work.
Great.
Another question.
I had two questions,
but
you have to care of
larger scales and just two people having college.
Um,
the,
the probably easier shorter one question is the,
would you describe it as a process?
Uh,
conflict?
I was hearing more kind of a have process.
I at task,
which he described as a task,
a conflict.
I was hearing that more.
It's kind of differences of objectives people have.
Is that a fair characteristic?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So it might be we disagree about what the goal is or it might be our goals are
we have goals and they conflict.
Yup.
Okay.
And I think so that those tensions in our organization are really good to have.
Right?
It's okay when when,
um,
departments or teams have different goals that conflict,
it's how you actually resolve the conflict or how you resolve the misalignment
that matters.
And that's the opportunity.
I sometimes say that managers have a responsibility to create tensions on an
organization.
If everyone in your,
in your team sees eye to eye and it really aligned,
you're not your job.
Right?
People need to bring in diverse perspectives.
They need to see things differently.
They need to disagree with the strategies or the goals because that's going to
make the work much more robust.
Okay,
great.
Next question.
Uh,
this might be a little bit of a difficult question,
but I didn't know if you had any advice you can give to women who there's kind
of that existing societal expectation that we're supposed to be agreeable.
Yeah,
so I could do a whole nother talk about the gender issues around conflict.
There's some great research about,
um,
women in negotiation and exactly the societal expectations.
So the research was done by,
um,
Hannah Reilly Bowles who was at Harvard Kennedy School and it shows that women
tend not to negotiate for themselves,
not because they don't know how to or don't have the skills,
but because they are penalized for doing so.
So both men and women who witness a woman negotiate are far more likely to say
they don't want to work with her.
Then if they see a men man do the same exact kind of negotiation.
Now I'm a big believer and you control what you can control.
If I knew how to change that societal expectation,
um,
I would do that.
That's what I would be spending my life doing.
Um,
but since we cannot control that,
it's you have to think a little bit about how do I deal with,
um,
deal with that expectation and that risk that if I do negotiate,
the answer is not to not negotiate.
Um,
what Hannah and also a woman named Debbie Cole,
but baths and advise as to what they call the eye we strategy.
So instead of negotiating for I your d or yourself,
your negotiation for we.
So how is what you want best for the organization or how is what you want best
for the team?
Um,
the classic example Hannah uses is Sheryl Sandberg when she negotiated her
salary with Mark Zuckerberg said before the salary negotiation said,
as your COO,
you want me to be good at negotiation?
So I'm going to show you right now how good I am at negotiation.
Right?
And she was negotiating for herself,
but she pitched it as I'm negotiating on behalf of you.
Right?
It's an incredibly tire,
some mental gymnastics to have to do.
But it's the reality that we live in.
And I do think that strategy of how is this best for the organization?
How is this best for my team?
That's another way women tend to get away when negotiation is,
my team really needs this.
Um,
you know,
again,
tiresome.
Wish we didn't have to do it,
but it is an in an effective way to get around that.
Any other questions
on,
over?
So during a very tense moment,
what kind of emotions do you suggest portraying?
So well,
okay,
that's uh,
that's a difficult,
actually find that more difficult than the gender question.
Partly because what you want to portray is authentic.
So if you're trying to portray that you're calm and collected and you're
actually fidgeting,
that is much worse than actually portraying your anger,
right?
Because what people interpret is a dissonance between what's happening.
And that dissonance is so confusing to people and it makes things really,
really difficult for it to actually have a conversation.
So first and foremost,
portray the authentic emotion you're having or the,
or what you can truly portray as,
as real.
So you're not communicating that,
that disagreement with your body language and your emotions.
That said,
I do think that,
um,
it's okay sometimes to express anger in a,
in a,
uh,
in a disagreement.
I had,
um,
you know,
a colleague who told had a really difficult situation with a colleague.
She had been really working hard to stay calm in these conversations.
Um,
every time he said something,
which she thought was completely off base,
you know,
she sort of did the deep breathing,
the anchoring,
and she was calm and she lost it one time and yelled and he stopped after the
meeting and said,
I never knew that I was frustrating you.
And I was like,
oh no.
Like she had spent all this time remaining calm and he,
she had actually never conveyed to him that he was driving her crazy.
And so,
um,
there are appropriate moments that the difference between what she did at that
moment and what most of us tend to do is that she had control.
So it wasn't a moment where she felt like she felt embarrassed that she had
yelled.
She had really reached a point where she was like,
I have no choice but to yell right now and to make clear how I feel.
And it was a rational decision for her to make.
So portray to things that are authentic,
be willing to portray negative emotions,
especially if you feel like your positions not being heard for the most part,
being calm is,
is great,
but only if you genuinely feel it.
The question's about smiling.
What do you do that so tell,
um,
is is the question,
should you not smile?
Well I guess cause you said disagreement is not unkindness I'm just wondering if
I was trying to project more warmth than empathy through smiling is either
helpful or unhelpful because potentially that could also cause some dissonance.
Yes.
Great.
So exactly that.
And I think that that's a great question because oftentimes when I'm helping
with a mediation,
what I see happen is people will,
you know,
say this happens all the time where people will have frame their message,
they're ready for the conversation and then they tried to spread their
discomfort over like 2000 word monologue to start it.
And it's like,
what's happening here?
Right?
So they portray,
I'm not feeling comfortable with this.
They portray I,
this is going to be a really tense,
difficult conversation.
What you want,
because disagreement shouldn't be unkind.
What you want to portray is I am comfortable with this situation.
I feel like it's okay to have this conversation smiling.
If you feel good about it and you sometimes you have to help people interpret or
not.
We always think we're much more transparent than we are.
So in this,
I say this around crying,
especially if you cry at work,
people are going to just think you're sad.
But people cry for all sorts of reasons.
They cry because they're mad.
They cry cards,
they're frustrated.
So if you're smiling or if you're crying or if you're doing something that's
that,
you can tell your,
the other person's not interpreting.
You can say,
you know,
I'm smiling because I really feel like this is an opportunity for us to resolve
this disagreement and productive way.
Right?
So really narrate what,
why you're doing what you're doing,
especially if you're interpreting a little bit of of discomfort.
But in that regard,
yes.
Smiling is great.
If you can portray,
I'm not uncomfortable with this conversation.
I'm glad we're having it.
That's a great way to set up the conversation for success.
Amy,
thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank [inaudible].